further hi I'm mazeed Abraham and I'm
answering at Davos the key question
which is what the countries can do to
improve the world every country shares
the same challenge that if they do
correctly they can definitely improve
the status of their population in the
world and that is education but we also
know that there are a lot of different
standards of Education across the
different countries and in particular
there there is a lot of points of views
that are very different across the
countries and what would be really
interesting is to create ultimately some
kind of a forum for young students may
be selected by a process like American
Idol but would be the Davos Idol would
be the world the world Idol where the
the local TV programs with the very
would take interest in the competition
at the local level will also cover it in
terms of what happens at a global level
and it would serve as a mechanism to
share a share a dialogue and eventually
hopefully share a common point of view
on the challenges that the world faces
what the different countries can do but
mostly to help to help make the opinions
and the ideas that are available in
different countries become more
harmonious and to learn about what other
people consider as important